hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the very useful pieces of advice
that Cicero provides us in his work on
friendship is that we need to actually
choose our friendships quite carefully
and that doesn't mean just at the very
beginning of a friendship that also
means that we need to every once in a
while reassess and think about is this
person genuinely a friend to me or
should I you might say downgrade that
relationship and in some way not view it
as a genuine friendship and this is
where a lot of people get themselves
into all sorts of problems and
difficulties in their lives
particularly if we understand friendship
as not just referring to what we
typically call friendship but also
romantic relationships or perhaps even
like you know partnerships or mentor
mentee relationships all these sorts of
things where we have some affection and
goodwill and a kind of intimacy that
allows us to make demands upon each
other if we've got the wrong sort of
people in this relationship then we're
laying ourselves in for all sorts of
problems even if we are good people we
are going to be stressed because of it
and the first bit of advice that he
provides us with which is actually
really great advice is in chapter 20
it's not the first bit of advice
actually it's this is the first bit that
I'm going to start with because it comes
you might say earlier in consideration
of our life process so he tells us that
as a rule decisions about friendship
should be formed after strength and
stability have been reached in mind and
age so decisions he's going to use this
word Judy qiyam and all sorts of
cognates of it for example here he says
that only know I'm a kid ti you to condi
so this is this is a gerund of
construction right it's saying that
decisions about or deciding about or
that which is to be decided should
happen under these conditions and so
what are the conditions he says
and stability Kurama Dantas Jung called
conformities Quay in guineas at IT
boosts right
so in guineas is our our mind our mental
capacities which would include not just
our reasoning capacities but perhaps you
might say and you know education of the
the emotions and desires and then he
uses the word for life stages or age
right so there's a lot of people that we
call friends early on in our lives who
maybe we shouldn't be calling friends
later on in any full sense he says that
men who in boyhood were devoted to
hunting and games of ball shouldn't keep
as their intimates those who they loved
at that period simply because they were
fond of the same pursuits why not well
because your your interest change and
just because somebody was a good
companion in you know playing on the
playground or maybe you went to camp
together or you know you you played
games together online or that doesn't
make them necessarily a good friend you
know I think back to my childhood I
haven't thought about this for a very
long time I had a lot of friends with
whom I I not only played quite a few
games and consumed media but we even
have like projects that we were gonna do
I had a I had a friend in fourth grade
and we were going to make it big by
designing missiles and we like made all
sorts of blueprints and then we were
planning to live in Brazil you know and
we were gonna build this this a palatial
place you know I haven't seen that guy
for probably 45 year no not 45 but close
to close to 40 years you know and I
haven't thought about him for perhaps 10
years or so we shouldn't we shouldn't
just stick with childhood friendships
because those are arbitrary right we
want to pick our friends on a better
basis
she's and he goes on and says I admit
that these are not to be neglected but
they're to be regarded in an entirely
different way difference of character is
attended by difference of taste and this
diversity of taste
severs friendships and he says nor is
there any other cause why good men
cannot be friends to wicked men or
wicked men to good men except that there
is the greatest possible distance
between them and character and in taste
so you may have a childhood friend who
turns out to have been a good good
person back then but has gone downhill
and you you really can't stay friends
with that person and this is something
that is very difficult for many people
Cicero's advice to us as he says in in
chapter 21 do not love too quickly or
love those who are unworthy of it know
and ignis right people who don't
actually deserve that affection how do
we know that that's the case well he
goes on and he says that what our
procedure ought to be he says there
there's only one security and one
provision against the ills of having you
know picked up the wrong sort of
friendship that is neither to enlist
your love too quickly in order to fix it
on unworthy men they are worthy of
friendship who have within their own
souls the reason for their being love so
right off the bat that tells us some
things you shouldn't be loving people
because they invite you to the best
parties you shouldn't be loving people
solely because they're you know
physically attractive you shouldn't be
loving people because they have a ton of
money or a fast car or we could go down
and you know a whole list about this
stuff you shouldn't love somebody
because they've they're enjoying
celebrity at this point in time you
should love them for what is within and
that takes a little bit more work to
find out doesn't it he says that this is
you know rather rare and the majority of
human beings don't recognize anything as
good unless it brings some profit they
regard their friends as they do cattle
you don't want to be friends with
somebody like that so you know his
advice there is that we should love our
friend after appraising them
not the reverse I'll actually read this
passage and appraise here again is this
word he says the UD Congress you know
when when you're judging them right he
says you should love your friend after
you've you've judged after you've
assayed after you've checked them out
you should not appraise him after you've
begun to love him why not well because
you're already biasing it and you're
already in a little bit too deep the
time to figure out is before you start
to feel all this affection whether
they're worthy of that affection or not
and so when we do this we exhibit a kind
of carelessness that he talks about in
chapter 32 23 says carelessness is so
great in regard to a relation absolutely
indispensable that it deserves the more
to be censured we should be saying what
are you thinking what are you doing
there was censured also means criticized
it says the one thing in human
experience about whose advantage all
human beings with one voice agree is
friendship so why aren't we most careful
with that well because we allow our
contingent experiences and affections to
suck us in and therefore we choose badly
now there is a difficulty here how do we
get to know what a person is really like
we can't just look at their profile from
the outside right
imagine that we're talking about a great
example of this think about dating all
right everybody has dating profiles and
very often when people show up to have
the date face to face they say things
like wow you don't look anything like
your picture and you know that's because
people put forward a false front they
downplay their bad characteristics or
they frame them in euphemistic ways you
know loves taking walks on the beach
could be a euphemism for odd
Cecily goes to the beach every single
day it's and they uh play whatever
positive characteristics they have that
is if they're the kind of person to do
that there are some people are
scrupulous scrupulously honest in the
dating game but there's probably not
that many of them right and so how do
you get to know what a person is really
like well if you're dating you have to
go on actual dates with them if you
think about romantic relationships you
have to go to a variety of different
sorts of situations and activities and
see whether the person who claims to
love sporting events really does enjoy
sporting events or the one who really
says they love walks on the beach is not
just trying to you know be romantic and
put ideas in your head but genuinely
enjoys that you also have to see whether
you're compatible with each other
whether you can stand to be in the same
room with each other long term and then
of course if it becomes sexual you have
to figure out a whole variety of things
like you know are you are you good with
what they do and are they good with what
you do and desire and you know are you
cool with each other's histories or is
that going to be an impediment all of
these things take a while to to learn
don't they so Cicero says that we we do
have to make tests of people he says
that at the same time it's very hard to
come to a decision without a trial while
such trial can only be made in actual
friendship so we have a little bit
paradox here friendship outruns the
judgment and takes away the opportunity
of the trial so he says it's the part of
wisdom or prudence that it checks the
headlong rush of goodwill as we would
that of a chariot put the brakes on
right and thereby so manage friendship
that we may in some degree put the
dispositions of friends as we do have
those of horses to a preliminary test
how do we do this he gives you some good
examples some men often give proof in a
petty money transaction how unstable
they are how unreliable they are while
others who could not have been
influenced by a trivial some are
discovered in one that is large if there
are any who think at base to prefer
money to friendship where shall we find
those who do not put office civil and
military rank high place and power above
friendship so that when the former
advantages are placed before them on one
side and the latter friendship on the
other side they will not much prefer the
former and so there's a lot of people
who when we when the chips are down as
we say they're going to fail so we
should make tests of them in order to
see whether they are really good friends
or not and this this is a a real issue
what are the characteristics of a
genuine true friend one of the things
that sister has discussed considerably
in here is the question of whether we
should do wrong things of a friend asks
us to do them and a good friend is not
going to do that because a good friend
is going to be a good person who won't
ask us to compromise ourselves in that
sort of way but he also identifies
several other characteristics of the
person that we want to be in in a
friendship with and notice these are all
internal to the person these are
character traits right so he tells us
that you know one one set of things that
we want from a person is what that they
are what he calls firm steadfast and
constant and this is this is quite
important right what would be the
opposite of this being unreliable
changing the kind of person who you
can't depend upon and so that's that's
one important aspect of it another way
of translating some of this is that they
are themselves loyal as well you can
rely upon them he then also tells us in
chapter 18 that the right course is to
choose for a friend one who is frank pry
Tierra Sol seeable commune em and
sympathetic
consent annum so what is being frank and
sociable and sympathetic means it means
that they reach out to us they are
connected with us they'll also tell us
when we're screwing up they're not going
to hide things from us there are going
to be sincere we might say or in the
Latin you know hone s them and that's to
us in this case because we're talking
about these friends and that means you
know sort of a straight shooter as we
say so these are characteristics that we
want in a friend how do we find out
whether they actually have them we do
have to put them to the test
so what we have here being advised by
Cicero in addition to the hey the
contingent things of childhood you know
be very careful with them or you know
the workplace or whatever else it
happens to be we also have this emphasis
on you know you've got it you've got to
try out some things and see how they
deal with things in a situation and then
you trust and love a bit more and then
you try something more and genuine
friends are going to pass every test
some people might actually say well you
know it's not really a real friendship
it's not good if you're putting your
friend to the test sister would actually
disagree and say a real friend would
have no problem being put to the test
because they're gonna realize that this
is a way for them to actually succeed
they show you that they're a good friend
whereas somebody who's a little bit
sketchy somebody who is a bit more
unreliable would probably get defensive
about being put to the test in part
because they're in insecure and
insincere when it comes to their own
friendship so very important to choose
our friends carefully according to
Cicero
you